welcome to the david pakman show i am
farron cousins i will be sitting in for
david pakman all of this week we've got
a lot of stuff to cover today everything
from buildback better to the january 6th
select committee a bunch of lawsuits to
talk about fox news michael cohen and
donald trump himself
so let's jump right into it obviously
the biggest news to come out over the
weekend is build back better
we went into this weekend with the
assumption that buildback better was
effectively on its deathbed
the democrats had said we're not going
to be able to pass it before christmas
like we had wanted to
then
talks broke down between joe manchin and
joe biden
and then on sunday morning
joe manchin goes on of course fox news
to let us know that nope
it's dead
there's nothing
that he can justify in this bill he says
to vote for it here is joe manchin in
his own words appearing on fox news
sunday morning
to tell us why we can't have nice things
take a look
i've always said this brett
if i can't go home and explain it
to the people of west virginia i can't
vote for it
and i cannot vote to continue with this
piece of legislation i just can't i've
tried everything humanly possible i
can't get there
you're done this is this is a no
this is a no
on this legislation i have tried
everything i know to do
and the president has worked diligently
he's been wonderful to work with so in
spite of the fact
that this bill is broadly supported
across the country including in west
virginia
in spite of the fact
that this bill would provide tangible
benefits
to millions upon millions of americans
again including his own constituents in
west virginia would make people's lives
better would allow low-income families
to have food for their children
i mean literally that's one of the
provisions in the bill by the way if you
weren't aware of that one that's an
often overlooked one would provide money
for families to get food for their
children over the summer when schools
are not in session and they can't get
those meals
and manchin says no i just i can't
justify this there's nothing i can do
i've looked at it every which way and
biden's been so great to me in the
negotiations but dang it
i i can't make the country a better
place is what he's telling us i can't
make the country
any better than it is
and of course after this appearance on
fox news his office did release a
statement and one of the things he
highlighted in his statement that he
personally released
was that it just transitions us
off of fossil fuels a little too quickly
for him
he didn't mention of course that he owns
a stake in a
dying coal company
just said nope is a little too quick for
us
to get on the renewable energy bandwagon
you know to revamp our energy structure
here in the united states to actually
help us
handle renewable energies nope just too
quick too much adds too much to the
deficit he tells us
would uh send inflation soaring which is
based on a faulty cbo score based on a
fraudulent bill by the way that
republicans sent to the cbo for scoring
that included things that one weren't in
the build back better act and it
extended provisions that are not
extended in the build back better act so
the republicans and joe manchin use this
as his justifications send this
fraudulent bill to the cbo thereby
getting a fraudulent score on it
showing all kinds of horrible things
that again couldn't happen because the
things they had in it weren't actually
in the bill
and joe manchin uses this knowingly
faulty piece of information
as his justification
for killing build back better saying i
just i can't i can't rationalize it i
can't justify it there's nothing i can
do
so
to hell with it
now he did
use a couple words in there that we need
to pay attention to he said this bill
this bill
so maybe that means build back better as
a whole or it could mean in its current
incarnation
so maybe joe manchin is signaling that
once they return from their holiday
break maybe he's willing to
continue working on it but i seriously
doubt that's the case i think joe
manchin
did send a strong message that he's done
with this bill
all together no matter what it does no
matter what kind of concessions that
president biden and the rest of the
democratic party make he is done
with build back better
which of course puts the democrats in a
really horrible position heading into
next year's midterms because this was
supposed to be the signature piece of
legislation right
okay we got infrastructure fantastic
a lot of the funding mechanisms for that
infrastructure bill are in buildback
better though
so there will be parts of the
infrastructure bill
that are not going to be able to be
fulfilled because the funding isn't
there because it was in buildback better
that's why the two bills were paired
together
it was supposed to come as a package
deal
and we only get
half of the bill
so that's going to be a big problem too
and again to do this in what is
effectively an election year because the
election is less than a year away at
this point
joe manchin is telling the democrats so
long and good luck
because this is going to come back to
haunt them
in the midterms
now there's things that are haunting
republicans and i'm going to get to that
later in the show don't you worry the
republicans have plenty of demons to
deal with on their own but right now the
democrats have to deal with their demon
and that is joe manchin and of course
there's everybody on social media has
got their personal opinion on it
you know a lot of people out there
saying mansion's just doing what the uh
establishment wants him to do that joe
biden is kind of glad that manchin did
this because he wasn't obviously
wholeheartedly supporting this
we can only speculate right
none of these people myself included
know exactly what the reasoning is
do we know that the corporate interests
want buildback better dead 100 percent
that's unequivocal
do we know for a fact that joe biden
you know doesn't really care about this
no we don't you can only speculate about
that and i don't like to get into that
kind of speculation
because it's not fair it's not accurate
honest reporting so we're going to avoid
the speculation
and focus on what is happening now and
right now based on joe manchin's own
words it does appear
that build back better
is effectively
dead
your internet activity and data is being
observed by a variety of parties they're
selling your information they're
deciding what you can access don't let
it happen to you i use atlas vpn to keep
my internet traffic private from isps
tech platforms online marketers even
governments and atlas vpn keeps me
protected against hackers people
eavesdropping on networks to steal your
information
if i turn on atlas vpn before logging
into netflix hulu or amazon i can access
streaming content from other countries i
can even watch stuff from argentina like
soccer i use atlas vpn on all of my
devices you install it you turn it on
once and then you just forget about it
and enjoy your privacy you can read
online about why vpns are so important
to use every day really something you
should have and atlasvpn is having a
huge sale giving you 86
off comes out to like a dollar 39 a
month for a subscription plus you'll get
three months free just go to atlas v dot
pn slash pacman and use the code pacman
the link is down below